so I've been getting bombarded with
these ads on YouTube lately all the
hustle culture passive income work from
your garage goulash of multi-level
marketing investment scams
cryptocurrency and business Guru
nonsense you know the stuff
here outside my garage just bought this
new Lamborghini want to know the best
way of making a big income online it's
making a lot of small incomes online I'm
here within 400 feet of an elementary
school to prove the haters wrong and to
tell you about an unmissable business
opportunity if you give me your money
I will use my magic powers
to guarantee 500 apy
but there was one in particular that's
under my skin that's got my undies in a
bunch because I and a friend kept
getting it and that's for these goddamn
Mickelson twins the new best way to make
money online that nobody's talking about
is something you've never heard of
before it's using audibles I've been
getting paid a thousand dollars a month
if not more just from this app on my
phone and I don't know if you can see
this but it's called audible these guys
are part of the class of online parasite
we'll be calling entrepreneurs a mix of
con artist and entrepreneur the kind of
thought fluencing bootstrapper who shows
you his Lambo before he shows you his
bookshelf to Prime you for a pitch on
how he can teach you how to be the best
small business Hustler you could be if
only you can put yourself into the right
grind set the phrase that we're going to
be hearing a lot as we cover the subject
is passive income that's the thing
that's being promised a source of income
that requires little or no active upkeep
in order to maintain like dividends
residuals and royalties you put in a
couple thousand hours writing a book or
making a movie and then once it's out
there you keep making money as long as
people keep buying it and getting people
to buy it is someone else's job the
concept in and of itself is not
fraudulent it is in fact a pretty sweet
deal and that's why we should support
Universal basic income as a political
policy but passive income in a
rhetorical context becomes a red flag
because of how it's deployed as a very
effective lure into fraudulent
businesses
entrepreneurs are a dime a dozen there's
mountains of these people out there
because as we'll explore it's pretty
cheap and it's reasonably legal we'll
get into more detail later but as
opposed to an outright fraud where you
sell something that doesn't exist or is
deeply misrepresented the trick of the
entrepreneur is to convince you to
massively overpay for something with
already extremely nebulous value advice
now if we evaluate the Griff by its own
logical mechanisms this is a sound
strategy like let's set aside morality
or ethics and just evaluate it as a
business advice costs very little to
manufacture requires no raw materials
weighs nothing and is evaluated in
hindsight so you have very low
production costs on one hand and a
heavily obfuscated value proposition
where you get to collect payment for a
product long before a naive buyer could
ever realize the value and on the
ethical slash legal side as long as the
advice you produce isn't constructed
about right lies and falsehoods you've
not explicitly conned anyone shallow
advice packaging common widely known
broadly available ineffective or out of
date information is still real advice so
who's to say what it's actually worth me
I'm the one who gets to decide what it's
worth I've got a certificate from the
Brad Defoe presidential Academy that
says so
[Music]
thank you
styling themselves as burnouts turned
publishing gurus these Dollar General
winklevi are the villain of today's
video but I do really want to stress
that these guys are not the end boss by
any metric they're not particularly
successful they're not big names in the
business they're only notorious in one
niche of the internet and they're not
just clones of each other but of
thousands of other similar Hustlers I
want to talk about them not because they
specifically need to be stopped though
they do need to be stopped that's
they should stop but because they are of
a type they are a representative sample
of a category of grift and also because
they're kind of incompetent and that
makes them entertaining like they're
just a little too honest about the
nature of the scam well they do utilize
a lot of the standard smoke screen
vocabulary and Hard Sell tactics they
are also often extremely straightforward
with how bad the whole scheme is which
goes to the nature of their grift they
promise to train you how to become a
grifter
the Mickelson twins are Christian and
the other one God I never remember his
name Christian is the point man in their
relationship he's the one who does all
the Talking in their videos he's the one
who does all the talking on their
podcast and he's the one whose name is
on all of the spam emails Rasmus his
name is Rasmus they're twins I don't
even know if I blurred the right one for
this joke in their personal mythology
they were underachieving burnouts
drifting through Community College and
working part-time at various low-paying
jobs like receptionist and takeout
delivery driver while smoking the weed
every day anyway we only lasted about
four months there because we couldn't
stand it I find it funny how we didn't
have the balls to quit or tell our
parents so we just stopped showing up
one day good times not we spent the next
three months smoking pot every single
day what percent of the stories they
tell about themselves are actually true
is definitely questionable they do not
espouse reliability as narrators and are
openly willing to just
make stuff up I feel like you're
wondering if you can do this too I tell
Charlotte she nods her head one sec I
take the backpack off my shoulders lay
it on the ground and unzip it I reach my
hand in and take out a mint condition
copy of the freedom shortcut by the
Mickelson twins take this it'll tell you
everything
the only part of that story that isn't
true is when I pulled out a copy of this
book and handed it to Charlotte although
if this book had existed at that time
that's definitely what would have
happened that said it's also kind and
not worth parsing in any meaningful
detail they're not noteworthy enough to
Merit an intense background check and
even their obvious Fabrications are
pretty low rent and unambitious who
cares if they hand out copies of their
book like business cards how else are
they going to get rid of them like they
have a whole thing about turning their
life around in community college and
busting ass to get straight A's but also
admit that all the courses they took
were low stakes filler if not outright
attendance based and then they
complained that they didn't actually
learn anything at college but you know
It's gotta be at least a little bit
above board since they were featured in
well-respected business Focus Magazine
Forbes
wait sorry there's a footnote featured
in a Forbes contributor post written by
Celine DeCosta a hustle culture Guru who
sells online courses on brand narrative
building Forbes contributors are unpaid
opinion bloggers with functionally no
editorial oversight and seeing as to how
DeCosta is herself a hustle Guru with a
specialty in building narrative and here
she's writing an article building brand
narrative for these guys on a platform
that has the adjacency to editorial
Prestige I don't want to accuse anyone
of anything I'm not saying there's
impropriety at play here but those facts
placed adjacent to each other might
suggest to an observer that there may
maybe be the silhouette of impropriety
that the possibility exists that this
may or may not have actually been a paid
promotional piece for the purpose of
search engine optimization and
legitimization
right
so there's a couple different layers to
the scheme that they've got going
so I built this grift map
to help us through it
get it perfect get it beautiful at the
top are the Mickelson twins they're
running what we'll call grift a grift a
is a guru Workshop book seminar series
private Facebook group where the twins
promise that they will teach you how to
unlock passive income this is ultimately
a pretty straightforward Workshop grift
and in this layer we can find all the
things that you would expect when you
visit the website there's a fake
countdown timer and the assertion that
space is limited the workshop is implied
to be live with meaningful time slots
but the presentation itself is of course
pre-recorded and Slots are available 24
hours a day Christian references things
that just happened like a certain number
of slots filling up despite the fact
that it's pre-recorded and thus that
thing obviously didn't just happen okay
guys do we have a deal there's a chat
function on your screen please go into
the chat and type deal if we have a deal
if you promise that you stick around to
the end and just hear what this is all
about all caps spam all right amazing
thank you so much you have to hurry and
lock in your spot as soon as I reveal
the button to join it's all high
pressure sales tactics upselling a
subscription service predictable to the
point that I would call this a grift
regardless of what their product
actually was and that's where it gets
interesting because what they're selling
is grift B grift B is called Made For
You audio books done for you audiobooks
done for you audio books now a done for
you audiobook or dfy for short is an
audiobook that you own and makes you
money but is written and narrated by
someone else so I want to be super clear
on this we call these done for you
audiobooks because all the work is done
for you so with these you do not need to
narrate anything yourself you do not
need to write anything yourself you do
not need to design any cover yourself
you do next to nothing when it comes to
actually creating your you're done for
you audiobook the idea is that you scour
Amazon and Audible for trending topics
specifically non-fiction topics with
very low standards of evidence or ones
favored by people who are hostile
towards science pick a couple that you
can smash together into a one sentence
summary hire a Ghostwriter to turn that
sentence into a short book hire a voice
actor to turn that short book into a
three-hour audio book then hire the
cheapest graphic designer you can find
to make a cover and spam the resulting
package on every ebook and audiobook
platform you can get access to for
example you might see that keto dieting
and self-hypnosis are trending both
subjects with dubious real world value
and extremely low standards of evidence
where you can say basically anything you
want and decide to combine the two into
a single book offloading the effort of
that nonsense task onto someone else and
then aggressively spamming the resulting
product on every platform available and
that is in and of itself a grift the
seminar series their trying to sell you
is it self-teaching you to become a
grifter whose product is low quality
exploitative spam and then of course
grift B feeds back into grift a because
the highest performers get recruited as
coaches and the expectation is that you
utilize their private Facebook groups to
review trade in order to maximize the
visibility of your spam they don't
outright call this review trading but
they do tell you to do all the
individual steps that constitute review
trading the next bonus you're getting is
free access to the private AIA audiobook
reviews group you go in you make a post
like this saying that you have a new
audiobook on Audible and that you want
to do some code swaps and leave it on as
a review on each other's audiobook and
then what will happen is you'll get a
bunch of responses from people who are
happy to leave an honest review on your
audiobook and then boom now you have a
good starting point for your reviews and
once you have 50 you now qualify for the
500 cash bonus okay so this whole
Arrangement is kind of extremely weird
in a whole bunch of ways the twins are
just barely successful enough at this to
have a presence that people have noticed
but they haven't learned how to make
good use of euphemisms and innuendos
well the core of it is low effort low
quality a lot of what they're telling
you to do is actually violating the
terms of service for the platforms that
you're using basically they're not smart
enough to disguise the fraudulent parts
of their system and have a habit of
saying the quiet part out loud so there
are a lot of ways to get reviews but the
most important thing is to always do it
ethically and buy the books and honestly
that can sometimes be a bit of a pain I
know I just admitted that you need to do
work to make this happen but don't let
that scare you I have yet to find
another model that requires less effort
money time and skill to be successful
and that's because I'm going to show you
how to get professionals to do most of
the hard work for you the seminar on the
whole is just a really good example of
quality filtering where the pitch is bad
which causes the targets to self-select
for a lower standard of quality it's the
same dynamic as the classic 419 fraud
the Nigerian prince scam like small
details of deranged framing like when
they call audible Amazon's best kept
secret well it's now time then to
introduce to you Amazon's best kept
secret audible basically that one line
is going to filter out so
so many people because the only people
who are going to hear that and just
accept it at face value are people who
just aren't that familiar with
you know
a lot of things a word from our sponsors
audible leave this scenario in the past
by signing up for audible which is why I
am most pleased to introduce you to
audible brought to you by audible
audible audible's audible audible
audible audible audible audible
audible.com thank you to Audible for
sponsoring this video and like
this is mean I feel mean saying it but
really Christian said it first their
target market is openly people who are
unskilled and aren't interested in
learning new skills like the kind of
person who would say I wrote a book
after doing the absolute bare minimum in
hiring someone else to write a book that
they then put a fake name on that's why
this is truly for beginners with no
prior experience or skills with making
money online or for people who just
don't have the time or desire to learn
any new skills because this is something
literally anyone can do including a few
case studies or testimonials make sense
in just about any business pitch but
there's diminishing returns with each
additional one you include and at a
certain point it takes on a character of
desperate insecurity now I don't know
that anyone can say you know
mathematically where that precise line
is but for sure this is over it here we
have Sarah Sarah is a new mom here we
have have an email that we received from
Patrick and here we have Tim from the
Netherlands here we have Chase here we
have Eric what you're about to see was
Trevor's Escape here we have Pierre Sean
Richard Kim Brandon here Gerald's
results Destiny Carmen here who's a
Limon from Bangladesh Ricardo Rob Gary
here like Yvonne here Solomon Dane and
here we have Kyle here we have Tom here
we have Abhishek Rick here Henny like
our no here Quan here who Amina like
Alessandro from Italy like Ed Juan
Matthias Mel Yvonne here hey Jack here
Juan here came here from Ahmad savera
Judy Jasmine Stacy Alex also like
there's something fishy going on here
here we have Kelly Rhodes award-winning
narrator of about 100 audiobooks female
from New York there's a picture of her
as well as some audio samples that you
can listen to okay but like I'm sorry
what
there's some hijinks at play that says
female that says male the samples sound
like this the majority of individuals
react to new ideas with apprehension
suspicion that even denial and an image
search tells me that this is a photo of
audiobook actress Christina Delaine who
is the voice of valiona in World of
Warcraft cataclysm you as the master
commands thoralium kill them cool okay
the point is what is the point of this
lie this has been manipulated effort
went into creating this lie but to what
end okay my my theory is that this
entire seminar is a Frankenstein
creation that they update bits and
pieces of every couple of months I
recently went back to watch it again in
order to try and interact with the live
moderator that is in theory on hand to
answer questions and got an entirely
different introduction YouTuber Emma
Thorne did a video about the twins back
in September for 2021 and the version of
the seminar she got is also
substantially the same with some very
funny differences you'll just say hey
Don I went through a few of your samples
and they were great I'd love for you to
narrate my audiobook wait so they're
asking him to do it less there's already
all sorts of audio Jank throughout the
video very obvious splices from
completely different recording
environments and so my original theory
was maybe what happened was at one point
this said Christina Delaine and she had
to tell them to piss off because they
were sending her low quality garbage
clients but I reached out to her and she
said she'd never heard of these guys
before and so it turns out that I don't
know what's up it's a level of deception
where the reasons for the deception
don't make any sense and the longer I
think about it the more I feel like I'm
going crazy like it's all just intended
to wear you down the excessive use of
shallow testimonials is there to
overload your critical thinking wear
down your skepticism and push past your
concerns so that when it comes time for
the Hard Sell they can literally tell
you to push past your concerns even if
you're a tiny bit unsure I need you to
go there and secure your spot what we've
learned is the people we want to work
with are those of you who take not just
fast action but instant action so when
you want something you take it because
that tells us you're a big time action
taker the seminar actually does include
a few really amazing morsels of
information not information about the
publishing industry or how to succeed in
any legitimate industry but for sure
some deeply entertaining insights into
the Twins and their operation for
example Christian drops this this right
here is just a fraction of our
audiobooks that I could fit on one
screen and most of these aren't even on
Audible yet just because I've been too
busy which is exactly why we're looking
for partners to do this with now this is
maybe initially impressive until you
spend literally anytime actively looking
at it because if you actually try and
ingest the information the details
rather than accepting the initial impact
at face value then you realize that most
of these are repeats of the 60 books
shown there's only 25 unique titles
stoicism for is up there three times how
to make your is on there twice and we've
even got two copies of
now why these were blurred out I have no
clue I don't know what they're hiding
there it could be
anything
all right one sec
[Music]
all right
how to make your wireless sex fantasies
Come True by Molly Harrison it's worth
noting that the stock photo used is like
one of the top 20 hits on Shutterstock
just by searching the term bondage 69
sex Secrets every man needs to know by
Frank Jameson and then last but hardly
least we've got stoicism
for [ __ ] by Stanley Barnes now
unfortunately I wasn't able to track
down copies of any of these because
despite what Christian said earlier this
right here is just a fraction of our
audiobooks that I could fit on one
screen and most of these aren't even on
Audible yet these are not books they
hadn't published yet when recording the
seminar in early 2022 but rather books
they had already published in 2018 and
2019 which have since been taken down in
fact of the 40 some odd books they are
listed as the publisher for on Google
Books a scant few of them are still
available in any capacity and even then
it seems to be mainly because I forgot
to check audible.com and instead checked
audible.ca now there's a good chance
that there's more out there that I just
didn't find across 45 different titles
they used 43 different pen names and the
only reason I found all these is because
they listed themselves as the publisher
and there's titles that I did find that
didn't come up in the publisher search
but came about through direct searches
it's all just boring details to say that
this is probably an incomplete list and
sadly I wasn't able to get my hands on a
copy of stoicism for [ __ ] or how to
make your wildest sex fantasies come
true not that it would matter if we did
because we know these two Ding Dongs
didn't actually write them so without
access to any of these books how are we
to discover what comes out of this
Sausage Factory why we give it a go
ourselves obviously now I didn't bother
signing up for their actual paid content
because it is transparently not going to
be worth the money what they promise is
part of that are some one-on-one calls
with their coaches who are just some
people who have worked their way up the
recruitment ranks MLM style access to a
case study that I'll talk about in a
second here and the big thing they claim
they will basically hand you your first
book subject saving you the step of
scouring audible trending topics for
something to copy we are going to choose
the topic of your first audiobook for
you that way results for you are much
faster much easier and most importantly
predictable the case study is also
pretty questionable since in the seminar
they already summarize what this guy did
to see his audiobook success when which
hilariously isn't even the Mickelson
method he just took a bunch of books he
had already written years and years ago
and got them turned into audio books
that's not made for you audiobooks
that's just audio books so it was
tempting purely to see just how bad I'd
get screwed on all this stuff especially
the one-on-one calls but the cost was
just too high they're asking for over
two thousand dollars and that's before
the inevitable upsells and I know it's
not worth this much because I'm a
certified worth decider
what I did decide to do
was follow their method I went on
Audible I looked up some keywords I
pretended to care about rankings and I
smashed a bunch of them together in an
incredibly tasteless combination because
I figured hey if we're going to prod
this system we might as well test its
limits now the Mickelson's recommend a
specific ghost writing service the urban
writers to the point that in the seminar
Christian says they're friends with the
owners and teases that buying the
premium AIA package gets you access to
things like discount codes we've worked
out an exclusive deal with our favorite
ghost riding company to provide you with
the lowest ghost riding prices humanly
possible it's the same deal normally
only we can get because we're friends
with the CEO following all of
Christian's advice minus the options
that no longer exist I picked the
cheapest package available 25 000 words
and let the urban writers make as many
decisions for me as possible so what did
I give them I wanted to test the ethical
limits of the system by presenting
something that was just ever so slightly
over the line because the hitch in this
is that once you submit your pitch to
the urban writers there's a whole back
end where the writers basically compete
to take posted projects obviously if I
cooked up something very deliberately
offensive there's a good chance that no
one would take it on as a project and I
wouldn't consider that to be an ethical
success of the system and on the off
chance someone behind the scenes did
take the job that's either because
they're so desperate that they're
willing to write hate speech or they
just already comfortable writing hate
speech and I didn't want to be party to
either of those possibilities so let's
keep it at least a little bit lighter
what if we make some just truly
irresponsible Health claims and use that
as the basis to create a book that's not
hateful
but still really shouldn't exist can
self-hypnosis treat epilepsy can it may
be
even cure it we don't have the answer to
that but we have a lot of leading
questions that'll let you come to that
conclusion on your own in treating
epilepsy with self-hypnosis a guide to a
free and Healthy You by Brad Defoe I
cooked up the title came up with a pen
name threw together an outline that felt
like it would at least be able to hit 25
000 words mashed in keto dieting and
something about prions just to cover my
bases tag wise and submitted it now the
urban writers as an outfit is worth some
scrutiny in their own right the urban
writers is the creation of Marco and
Natasha moutinho a husband and wife team
of Canadian
entrepreneurs
what's up everyone I'm Marco and I'm
Natasha and we're the martinos the urban
writers was founded in 2017 as a
division of Dibley Inc alongside Dibley
publishing both also creations of the
matinos no I don't know why their own
name is misspelled on their own website
the urban writers manages to look mostly
legit at first blush if you don't know
anything about the industry of ghost
writing then it all sounds normal
the urban writers functions as a job
posting board for ghost writing contract
in the Mickelson presentation it is
postured as though there's the option to
just like submit something and walk away
let tuw assign a writer and then just
come back and pick up the deliverables
when it's all done maybe that was the
case in the past but that was not
accurate to my experience and I suspect
I know why see the critical word in
there was a sign if the urban writers
are assigning projects to specific
writers then that's not a contractor
relationship that person is an employee
so and you probably already guessed this
the urban writers is in fact a post Uber
gig economy nightmare where Freelancers
are treated like employees to the
maximum extent the owners can get away
with what makes us unique is the culture
we have fostered within our community
yeah sure so my pitch gets picked up by
Scott Scott is not his real name because
writers at tuw are not permitted to use
anything other than a pen name and are
subject to disciplinary action if they
use their real names disclose their real
names or provide a means of being
contacted outside the platform they're
also not free to negotiate their own
rates but we'll get back to that later
Scott is a champion Scott took all
Brad's insane ideas about prions and
keto and self-hypnosis and epilepsy and
very delicately tie them together into a
somewhat morally defensible product just
to really drive this point we like Scott
the end result is not good it's more or
less exactly what you would expect but
it exists and was delivered on time and
that alone is something of a miracle
before I get into some of the details
about the book I want to talk a bit
about those expectations and kind of
broadly about ghost writing itself I do
not mean for this to be in any way an
impunment of ghost writing as a craft
it's a niche of writing that requires
professionalism and a set of specific
skills ghost writers need to be able to
adopt the voice of their subject and
typically need to work under
particularly rigorous delivery timelines
something not all writers can do so a
bunch of the flaws and failings that
we're going to go into are not strictly
the result of ghost writing in and of
itself but are the product of the
overall environment that is curated so
when I say it's exactly what you would
expect I mean that if you know a thing
or two about writing long-form
nonfiction then you can probably look at
the expectations and draw a few natural
conclusions about what the end product
more or less needs to look like the
deliverable is 25 000 words the
turnaround is 30 days with a few days in
there for administrative slop so
basically 25 days of actual writing
average of 1 000 words per day that's a
pretty stiff Pace but not an absurd
requirement of a professional the big
hitch there is research the main thing
that slows down a non-fiction writer is
the need to look stuff up source quotes
and fact check claims depending on the
subject it might take a really long time
just to find a couple useful sources and
often the way that you discover a source
is garbage is by spending hours and
hours processing it nothing stings quite
as much as spending a whole bunch of
time tracking down some obscure 19th
century text only to then spend several
more hours reading it only to then come
to the conclusion that it contains no
insights no new information and is
incredibly poorly written and not worth
quoting so with these constraints in
mind the number one prediction we can
make is that the final product is more
likely than not going to be quite
shallow and repetitive leaning heavily
on easily available sources the
timelines are just too tight to really
delve into the subject or worry about
being creative and clever and you just
have to imagine that the emotional
investment is going to be pretty low if
you are reading this you a friend or a
loved one have likely been diagnosed
with epilepsy perhaps it's a recent
diagnosis or you've been living with it
for years regardless you are no doubt
familiar with the challenges that come
with this disease however there are
limits to Conventional medicine epilepsy
treatments don't work for everyone
sometimes they are ineffective other
times they are too time consuming in the
search for respite from epilepsy
sometimes the remedy comes with its own
set of caveats I've studied hypnotherapy
for years and have been a firm believer
in the power of self-hypnosis let's
pause for a second and talk about ethics
I said one of my goals in this was to
push the ethical boundaries of the
system but shockingly the system doesn't
have any from the urban writer Zone
training materials do books need to be
objective the short answer is not always
many of our non-fiction customers have
books written because they want to
Market their business product or to
further their business interests they do
not necessarily want both sides of the
story told especially when an objective
book might harm their business interests
sales potential customer base
a customer might not be too pleased if
our writers point out that they're
actually selling something that's
ineffective to their clients or that
their business claims are
unsubstantiated so just openly if the
customer wants you to lie misrepresent
facts or make fraudulent claims your job
is to facilitate that they're the one
taking credit for it just you know
lower your standards there's nothing
legal about that per se but it's it's
telling it's indicative of the internal
culture of the company that they're like
oh yeah this is just what we do now I
don't want to make too much fun of
treating epilepsy with self-hypnosis a
guide to a free and Healthy You by Brad
Defoe because ultimately it's a product
that I got someone else to make the
insane claims like sexual activity
increases your prion score and thus
impedes self-hypnosis and makes you more
susceptible to epilepsy is not some
organic nonsense it is entirely
synthetic even if the person doing the
actual writing needed to behave as
though the request was sincere and for
the most part somewhat predictably Scott
minimized the presence of this Insanity
mostly leaning on shallow easily
available information in order to meet
word count most of the book like
approaching two-thirds is just defining
stuff or Loosely summarizing very basic
history the end result is pretty much
what we were expecting which would
support our hypothesis about what needs
to be done to get something like this
done but I'm not satisfied with that
that feels too
distant too sterile like sure I know
what it's like to write thousands of
words of non-fiction I know what it's
like to do research and I even vaguely
remember what it's like to have
meaningful deadlines but that's not the
same thing the only way to really
properly visualize what it means to try
and churn out this kind of content
militridus is if we actually did it
ourselves and then documented the whole
process
it's fine it's fine so I've been digging
into these ghost writing outfits and
really looking at the numbers that are
involved so I'm commissioning this book
from the undergrad writers and then in
parallel with that I am going to try to
also write a book at the same pace and
the topic that I've selected for myself
at the moment is a skeptic's guide to
hypnosis so the book is going to be 25
000 words I'm giving myself a month to
do it they assume a thousand words per
day so that's 25 writing days plus five
days for like editing an administrative
slop and then delivery to the client
so I want to try to keep Pace with that
so I'm gonna try to do a thousand words
per day for 25 days on the subject of
hypnosis
okay got some developments just from
last
night so I've got the outline and I have
instinctively just structured it the
same as I structured the outlines for
scripts and I could just try to write it
the way that I normally would and then
afterwards uh try to bulk up the word
count basically that that once it's once
it's done done once it's like drafted
then just try to make it longer until it
uh until it hits word count now my worry
about that is that if I do it that way
I will write myself into too many
corners my normal style will get in the
way of accomplishing the accomplishing
the task so that's what I'm worried
about the the other approach would be to
just try to brute force it more or less
from the beginning and just like
beginning to end plow forward through it
like what chapter are you on you're
writing that chapter of course many
people outright dismiss hypnosis has a
thing entirely insisting that it's all
in at Rod hoax and the motivations for
making this claim aren't without
justification there's a lot of
conflicting sometimes incoherent
information out there people claiming
that hypnosis is the best way to quit
smoking or rewire your eating habits
incredulous claims about hypnotic
regression and of course famous Tales of
hypnosis being used to unlock the truth
about alien abductions
oh
boy okay so uh so I'm I'm behind I'm
already like uh
4 000 words behind so that's not a great
uh that's not a great rate even just
having to like answer emails in the
morning on a different subject
um can like really
delay how quickly I can get into a
mindset to think about this this book
project that's a me problem yeah so I
think I'm going to stop this find one of
these Mickelson books
um and like just like read the free
excerpts whatever like just get the
voice just try to get the get that
writing voice and then go back and try
and stretch what I've got like taffy
okay today was fun but I think my
batteries are dying so I'm gonna try to
be quick here uh I managed to get
through over 2500 words today I learned
some like
really weird
interesting historical facts in uh in
writing about the history of hypnosis
turns out that Mesmer uh
was a real strange guy
yeah I'm feeling good about today went
well
foreign
where we're halfway through
we're more or less halfway through the
uh
writing period
um we're not not quite half done the
book we're behind any part where I need
to do like synthesis research
is
is substantially more difficult so my
normal worry with my method is that I
end up with these like weird Junctions
and weird repetitions and blah blah blah
maybe that's just not a problem now yeah
it's um it's getting harder I don't know
I don't know there's some things that
I'm worried about
um
and I'm behind
okay
oh
Okay so yesterday was intensely
frustrating I was in I was in a bad mood
I couldn't
Focus nothing was happening and I think
the big thing was is that I was doing
sort of the math on things
and that's what was making me like kind
of acutely
angry I just didn't feel like I was
making like sufficient progress that
like my like I was not doing enough to
overcome my my style and instincts I had
made what felt like a lot of progress
um and it was still just like basically
like almost like half as long as it
needed to be however I'm trying to pad
them it's just not enough and I realized
two
key strategies two key techniques
for padding word count that that would
meet my criteria so the first one
definitions Define words spend a lot of
time defining words you can eat up a lot
of word count and like at very low
effort by just including more
definitions classic classic coping
technique of the the stressed freshmen
just include more definitions the other
is
quotations use use more quotations and
uh over quote the ghost writing company
that that I've uh commissioned uh won't
allow their writers to have more than 10
percent of a book be
quotation okay so we'll take that as a
baseline ten percent of a book is a lot
of the book so that's like five pages
because there's an entire like two days
of writing that you can are just gimmies
so rather than treating that ten percent
as a limit treat it as a budget use it
or lose it Canadian magicians and
Skeptics Penn and Teller on their 2004
program [ __ ] dismiss stage hypnosis
as me leave Collective imagination which
does strike me but it's dismissing a
sandwich as mainly a collection of bread
fillings and condiments perhaps the most
fascinating thing about hypnosis
demonstrated by the state hypnotist is
the mundanity of it the persuasive power
of set and setting the power of
suggestion in a collaborative negotiated
relationship the Amplified state of
being open to being persuaded and the
ways in which that is in and of itself
interesting
foreign
I want to get this done with it's pretty
bad from uh from a structural standpoint
and there's not really a clear
Focus so
it's all right
that's all right
um
we're over halfway
we're halfway there we got
10 days to do the remaining half
so
is what it is
okay I have
eight days remaining
I have somehow
managed to find it within me after two
days of writer's block
to to not not merely get caught up but
actually
get fully completely ahead of quota
I wrote over 4 000 words today
there's walking immediately above me
which uh amounts to two whole chapters
based off of our 2000 words per chapter
uh uh uh original original plan there's
there's eight days remaining and my
words per day is now under a thousand
we're ahead at this moment
I feel just
completely drained of ideas but but
I have yet to write the introduction and
the conclusion
which which can be a lot more
autobiographical
those those are the ones that I can very
easily pad by just telling stories about
myself and and the journey that I have
now taken
I was I was feeling overwhelmed this
morning and now now I'm in a good mood
oh that could come crumbling down real
fast
I'm so close I'm so close to done
I've got 3 500 Words remaining where do
I put them as I get closer to the end it
both gets easier because it's like the
the about the amount that I need to
write gets less
but I'm also like kind of closing off
like where where I can just put large
blocks of new stuff it's getting easier
and it's getting harder I just gotta
figure out like where where can I get
those
it's just that simple it's that simple
and that hard
twenty five thousand
and nine words these last
these last 2 000 words have been so
stressful just just like not not neces I
don't want to say not hard because it
was clearly hard it was it was just it
was like but it is it's just it's a
process of going through and figuring
out like what you can cram in that's not
going to really involve
like
new research because research
absolutely
murders the the
like pay per hour okay so I want to do a
numbers breakdown let's get let's get
some charts in here
okay
the standard rate for a ghost writer at
this level is about 10 cents per word or
ten dollars per 100 words at that rate
twenty five thousand words should cost
about twenty five hundred dollars that
may seem expensive at first blush but
let's really break it down on a 25-day
writing cycle that's only a hundred
dollars per day if you constrain it to
eight hours of work a day that's only
12.50 an hour not the worst but it's not
really anything to write home about that
25-day cycle also comes with the
expectation of writing 1 000 words per
day which as has been demonstrated is a
pretty substantial ask if the process of
writing also includes meaningful amounts
of research it is by no means impossible
if you have the luxury of treating it as
a full-time job which 10 cents per word
kinda just barely crosses the line on
and this 25-day expectation doesn't
include slack for the editing process if
you maintain this pace and do one book a
month you're only making 3 thirty
thousand per year before taxes depending
on what city you live in that might be
an honest modest living or barely
covering for your half of the bunk bed
in my own writing exercise I kept track
of all the hours I was spending doing
research the hours I was spending
physically writing and all in all it
took me a little over 84 hours to throw
together a very low quality very
repetitive book and while those hours
reflect the time I was spending at the
computer actively working with a
stopwatch running they don't reflect the
time I spent worrying about it thinking
about it in the shower looking up
information on my phone at the grocery
store and generally letting it ruin my
life even the days where I wasn't
sitting down and working on it the days
where I was burnt out and miserable
those days were still about the book
avoiding working on the book takes
almost as much energy as working on it
in fact the reason the time spent
actively writing is so low is because I
was actively trying to keep it low
because I and Scott were not being paid
10 cents per word for the rising package
with the urban writers I paid
603.75 to cover both writing and editing
my writer was paid one cent per word 250
dollars for 25 000 words 250 of that 603
goes to the writer the rest is a split
almost 50 50 between the editor and tuw
itself in one sense I spent only 84
hours writing a skeptic's guide to
hypnosis honestly not that absurd in
another sense I spent 84 hours writing
it at this pay rate at one cent per word
that's
2.97 cents an hour the urban writers
don't just need to do 1000 words per day
in order to make something even
resembling a living they need to do one
thousand words per hour
and all of this I'm just I'm I'm just
sitting here thinking about the fact
that
this is the most like this as an
exercise is so comically stacked in my
favor because I know exactly what it is
I know what my standards are
and
I I know that I as the commissioning
person have
I'm I'm not going to read a submission
that I make and go Oh no you're taking
this the completely wrong direction that
I want you know no I don't want you to
talk about like this aspect I don't want
you to frame it this way I don't want
you to discuss these elements I'm I'm
not going to surprise myself with those
kind of constraints because I am the
person who would be the source of those
constraints
um which means that you know there's
there's no real stress and while I was
tracking
while I was tracking my like theoretical
pay no one is actually going to pay me
250 bucks now that the book's done so
that's not a stressor that was hanging
over my head all of the stressors that I
needed to deal with in this exercise are
purely self-inflicted it's trying to
stay to a schedule it's trying to
maximize
words per hour in order to keep a
derived theoretical number from getting
just awful they're fake rules that I
have self-imposed as a creative exercise
in order to get a glimpse at like what
is required in order to do this thing
and in order to like have a material
have material to use as I work through
the rest of uh the rest of the process
of this ecosystem and and that's not you
know authentic
um so I just I I am keenly aware of the
ways in which my interaction with this
is just very very emotionally different
from someone who
is relying on this for income uh if I
actually had the threat of losing you
know my grocery money if I didn't have
this done in
two more days
I I don't think I would be able to work
at all I think that would be just like a
paralyzing amount of extra stress like
if I needed this money if I needed that
250 dollars then I would absolutely be
doing you know whatever whatever it took
if I can write this whole thing in three
weeks that gives me a week of slop for
revisions and changes and getting sick
and just dealing with life if I can
write it in two weeks then I I like it
doesn't it doesn't matter that my words
per hour and my pay per hour got bad I'm
just I'm just done it that much faster
and in theory if I can turn it in and
they can sign off on it and we can
deliver I can start the next project and
I might make 500 bucks this month that's
this miserable that's nightmarish
because it's it's terrible it's just an
awful awful awful arrangement
so
I'm I'm under No Illusion that what I
did is
comparable
to the bad deal that
um
others are are actually operating under
and you know what this makes some sense
in the scope of things because at the
end of the day
this is what the urban writers was
founded to do dibly publishing the thing
the motinos made shortly before making
the urban writers let's take a look at
their output
a complete guide to mining
cryptocurrency a stoic's journey
mindfulness for beginners how to stop
procrastinating manifesting how to use
the law of attraction to manifest your
dreams why this all sounds like the
Mickelson method in March 2017 Marco and
Natasha decided to start a
self-publishing business in the pursuit
of earning passive income this evolved
into the urban writers we know and love
today
the urban writers exist specifically
because this grift needed a steady
source of cheap writers the numbers just
don't work out if you have to pay
writers twenty five hundred dollars per
book which as we've already pointed out
is still not great pay bringing this all
back to the Grift map we've got the
Mickelson's doing grift a which is
teaching you how to do grift B which
involves utilizing outfits like the
urban writers who are themselves engaged
in grift C which is basically
the whole of the gig economy
all of this is just trying to exploit
the next person down the chain readers
and actual creatives the people who
actually make stuff are just gristle to
be churned through
let's actually just for a bit not talk
about audiobook income Academy the
seminar level grift but the actual
merits of the material that they teach
like let's evaluate it as though it were
a real class that was actually trying to
teach you to do something
there are in my mind two major
outstanding problems with the Mickelson
method the first is that it makes you
into the worst kind of client possible
Brad Defoe was not a good client but he
also didn't take the Mickelson method
100 seriously as a character Brad wanted
a book about a subject that he cared
about even if he had kooky ideas low
standards a propensity for lying and a
gullibility for any woo that crosses his
path it can get so much worse the ideal
client for someone at the urban writers
is someone who is to one degree or
another an expert in their field but not
a writer they can provide the writer
with sources explain Concepts correct
mistakes and help structure and focus
the product we can express their
relationship like this a writer slash
expert that's just an author it's going
to be someone like Carl Sagan both
unaccomplished scientist and a
compelling and prolific Communicator non
writer slash expert this is someone who
hires a Ghostwriter will represent that
one with JFK a talented man and skilled
orator who wrote basically nothing with
his name on it really this one extends
to most politicians actors and athletes
and the majority of autobiographies fall
into this category a writer slash
non-expert that's a ghost writer
Mickelson students are the worst Square
on the board neither writers nor experts
clients who specifically don't know much
of anything about their chosen subjects
and don't care they didn't decide to
write a book about a subject that
they're interested in they chose a
subject that had favorable metrics on
the storefront if the writer runs into
problems with the client's outline the
client can't help combined with the
urban writer's internal structure the
arrangement is basically guaranteed to
produce boring inaccurate junk that
leans very heavily on endlessly
rewording shallow dives into widely
available information at every stage of
their process they tell you to take the
cheapest option and wherever possible to
haggle the price down even lower the
most important part is that you do not
use a mainstream ghost riding company
like this because we don't want to pay
this much for our manuscript why because
we simply don't have to and because most
narrators are just trying to build their
portfolio so they will narrate
audiobooks for almost any price you'll
just say hey Don I went through a few of
your samples and they were great I'd
love for you to narrate my audiobook
would you do it for a 30 per finished
hour rate they are training their
students to be nightmare clients the
second is that it just doesn't actually
work very well part of that is because
it's self-defeating people who are
willing to shamelessly commission a book
about a nonsense subject that they know
nothing about purely because it shows up
in a word cloud of popular subjects
they like the entire thing is so openly
allergic to work and expertise the that
the personality Matrix needed to succeed
basically eliminates people who aren't
sociopaths by definition this stuff is
low effort to produce which means
there's a ton of competition and while
corporations like Amazon clearly have an
incredible tolerance for spam trash and
misinformation they do still have their
limits taken as a whole the method is a
machine structure to produce low quality
low content junk that will only attract
legitimate readers and listeners by
deception and like you you know things
are just dire when I'm telling you that
the crystal healing crowd deserves
better than what they're getting from
these guys the thing is
that they know it doesn't work they
don't use their own method at least not
anymore remember all these this right
here is just a fraction of our
audiobooks that I could fit on one
screen and most of these aren't even on
Audible yet just because I've been too
busy and remember this little tidbit
these are not books they hadn't
published yet when recording the seminar
in early 2022 but rather books they had
already published in 2018 and 2019 which
have since been taken down all their
junk is from 2018 and 2019. they were
doing this they were making low quality
audiobook spam but they don't do it
anymore they've stopped and pivoted to
selling the method instead
word on the street is that they started
trying to post Spanish versions of their
books by running them through Google
translate and Amazon nuked their entire
ACX account and banned them from the
platform for Life the twins aren't
selling you a method that they're using
they're selling you a method that
they've already used up they ran the
grift all the way to its natural
conclusion there was a narrow window of
time where audible's Gates were wide
open but there wasn't a lot of
competition yet that first Movers On
generating SEO spam could in fact make a
pretty tidy profit without it being too
much of a gamble but that window is
closed now the time has passed because
when it comes to making money online as
a beginner you want to find something
that has low competition and audible is
that new thing it's so new that there's
not many people doing this the well
isn't dry strictly speaking low quality
dieting Wellness new age and crypto
garbage will always be a viable Niche to
some degree but there's a hell of a a
lot of people lined up around it because
they are right about one thing it's easy
it's not easy for the Scots of the world
to crank out 25 000 words a month on
nonsense for less than three dollars an
hour Scott's life sucks but it's pretty
easy to find a Scott to inflict that on
because there's a whole ecosystem of
people willing to trick people like
Scott into thinking they're getting a
good deal and to some degree it's a sign
of the times these kinds of griffs never
go away they're always somewhere in the
background but guys like this come out
of the woodwork when times are tough
what really gets to me what really makes
me angry is that they always hit on the
same button where they shift the blame
self-publishing as a concept has
incredible power to allow voices that
big publishing corporations didn't see
as widely marketable in the past to get
their stories out there to the people
who want to read them what's up my
fellow small business supporters that's
how I greet everyone on my channel Savvy
writes books Dan thank you so much for
having me on your Channel today to talk
about the very important topic of
publishing industry scams especially in
relation to the Mickelson twins who are
out here making an absolute mockery of
my industry with the rise of
self-publishing has of course come the
people who want to cash in on the
shovels that they can sell to aspiring
authors who see gold available through
selling books on a top online retailer
like Amazon as a result there is nothing
that annoys me more than people like the
Mickelson twins who take the concept of
self-publishing which should be a
groundbreak taking form of Industry
disruption for small presses and turn it
into a multi-level marketing style grift
for example take their podcast episode
is Amazon publishing guaranteed to work
which is full of MLM adjacent dog
whistles and some of the worst elements
of toxic work culture you know you hear
those people they come to us and say
listen I've tried eight different things
online before you know they always have
tears in their eyes I've done eight
courses and they were all scams none of
them worked and it's because they have
their understanding is that when you
jump into the business model it just
makes money for you when they say Amazon
publishing they're talking about their
specific methods of publishing on Amazon
that you can pay them for it it's as
close to
a foolproof business as it gets as long
as you actually do the work it's very
very hard to lose money this is how many
business gurus and MLM scammers alike
tend to block themselves off from
criticism by Framing any failure as your
fault rather than a flaw in the system
itself from the start the Mickelson
twins set us up with this expectation
they start telling you that what you
need to do in order to work hard enough
and not give up your dream they tell us
success is guaranteed if you allow it to
be guaranteed how you fail is you quit
this mentality plays into the way that
many mlms business gurus and overall
entrepreneurial grifters prey on our
tendency to give in to the sunk cost
fallacy if we've come this far we'd be
failures to quit right even if the next
step involves paying someone else even
more money plus it has a little bit of
that manifestation BS slid in there as a
treat success is guaranteed if you allow
it to be guaranteed because I'm the only
thing holding myself back right of
course I'm just scared of success
everyone who isn't a billionaire must
have manifested their failures by being
too scared to work hard those things you
need to do to work hard of course
include investing more money in yourself
which is really code for investing more
money with them people who have been
listening to us for a while have heard
us say this many times I 100 subscribe
to the belief that and I mean this
literally is that
success is inevitable guaranteed it is
guaranteed if you allow it to be
guaranteed it is a choice that is on
that is in your control
how you fail is you quit and quitting is
a decision that you made and then I know
what some people are going to think they
say no I ran out of money so that was
not me quitting I just didn't have a
choice
[ __ ] get a second job a third
job do whatever you need to do start
saving money stop spending your money
then boom now you have your money back
now and then get back to work and you
know what really sucks about all this a
lot of the things they're saying in this
episode are factually true
in a vacuum but when applied to their
business model which like an MLM is
basically a course on how to sell
shovels to other people who hope to dig
up the gold the same language becomes
manipulative because it's not meant to
work in that context if you made your
own lipstick at home and it made
people's lips swell up 10 sizes and
break out in hives you'd also lose money
and that would be your own fault but if
you join Mary Kay and lose money that's
the company's fault because that company
thrusts you into an oversaturated
industry with an unsustainable long-term
model the same applies here
for months now since signing up for
their mailing list I've been getting the
most amazing spam minutes after
finishing the seminar I received an
email ominously titled Dan I warned you
guaranteed plan for staying broke always
hang around with broke people what to do
with your family and friends aren't
supportive spoiler the answer is give
them money to join their private
Facebook group what do I do if my
parents partner friends aren't being
supportive of my decision to pursue
audiobooks you're not pursuing
you're not you're not pursuing
audiobooks you're you're building a
business generating spam in the form of
audio books there is this truly
beautiful double think exercise the
Mickelson's play in all of this which is
to assert on one hand that this is a
process that requires very very little
input from you the operator that you get
to kick back and literally just
gleefully exploit the labor of others as
they turn out low quality trash credited
to a dozen different pen names on your
behalf but also that doing all of this
will bring you the same Pride respect
and Prestige from family and peers that
you would get from actually writing a
book or even just meaningfully
contributing to a ghost written book
about a subject that you actually know
something about and care about and put
your name on we sell books and
audiobooks online oh you're writers
that's very cool we both laugh to
ourselves flattered that he had mistaken
us for professional writers definitely
not far from it Christian says we don't
write our books ourselves we hire
professionals to do that for us we just
published the books and audiobooks and
get sent the earnings at the end of
every month
you can do that but you have to split
profits with them right he asks no they
work for a one-time fee says Christian I
own the book 100 and only split profits
with Amazon
so you're telling me you literally have
no writing skills yet it's what you do
for a living and how you're able to live
in Bali
exactly so this right here is Don
Jacobson he is an experienced jazz radio
and live narrator imagine having a radio
broadcaster narrate your audiobook
imagine showing that's off to your
friends and family when they ask you how
is it you were able to quit your job
again and do what you want then you just
showed them your audiobook narrated by
Don Jacobson the radio broadcaster and
that's something you can be really proud
of there's this bit that kind of makes
me laugh the Christian is talking about
how proud will you be when you tell your
family that you've got a you know a DJ
narrating your book that you didn't
write and I'm like why would you feel
proud of that all you've done is send a
message saying can I pay you less than
your rate there's a large percentage of
people that believe that buying the
course and going through the content is
equivalent to actually building the
business we are switching from a
do-it-yourself course which is what AIA
was to a proven and all-inclusive done
for you partnership where we do all the
heavy lifting for you so you no longer
have to rely on yourself to have success
now you're getting us the people that
don't have good results I can say with
the utmost certainty
with no hesitation whatsoever their
books are not good but now we're taking
it a step further by doing things like
straight up giving you a winning
audiobook topic to go out and list on
Audible and multiply with do you want to
dominate social media in 2019
would you like to learn all about social
media marketing are you looking to take
your business to new heights with
up-to-date social media marketing but
that's not the case with publishing to
fail at publishing
is incredibly challenging challenging
with the caveat as long as you do the
work in other words someone else does
the work but we get paid that's how the
whole model works the biggest Mantra the
Golden Rule with publishing is what you
put out is what you get back if you
garbage in garbage out if you put in
poor quality work you're going to get a
poor quality result you do not need to
narrate anything yourself you do not
need to write anything yourself you do
not need to design any cover yourself
you do next to nothing when it comes to
actually creating your done for you
audiobook and we need you to show your
commitment because if you aren't
committed then we shouldn't invest our
time our money our team our everything
in you because we're in this together
now [ __ ] get a second job a
third job do whatever you need to do
start saving money stop spending your
money then boom now you have your money
back now and then get back to work
let's close this out the mickelsons are
not unique as I said before they are
simply an entertaining example of a type
they're not alone and they're not even
Flying Solo in their own Venture this
thing that they're doing is part of a
whole ecosystem it relies to some degree
on the complicity of the platforms
Amazon has an incredibly high tolerance
for low value repetitive spam though to
give Amazon an absolutely microscopic
amount of credit they do have their
limits and people are of actively
evading the rules more directly the
mickelsons rely on gig economy
Arrangements like the urban writers
because the only way the economics work
out is if you can underpay your writer
90 the urban writers in turn use the
Uber model they onboard far far more
writers than they have clients to
service and make writers compete with
each other ensuring that anyone looking
to turn out content Mill gristle will
enjoy quick turnarounds and low prices
now I didn't post treating epilepsy with
self-hypnosis a guide to a free and
healthy you on to Kindle or audible
because like I just don't want it
wandering free it's a book that
shouldn't exist but I did post a
skeptic's guide to hypnosis since that
one is just a little sloppy caveats on
that I didn't do any review trading I
didn't spam it anywhere and
definitionally I think a book with
skeptic in the title is not going to hit
the typical target market but at the
root I actually just took the
Mickelson's at their word and pushed it
out onto Amazon to make me some passive
income in the months that a skeptic's
guide to hypnosis has been available it
has sold one copy
they hedge their pitch by saying that
their results are real but not
indicative nor a promise and that's
legally accurate but not spiritually the
implication that they allow to follow
that disclaimer is that while their
success and the success of all the
testimonials they include is exceptional
your success will probably be
proportional if you're making even 10
percent of their highest performers a
mere one-tenth then that's still a few
hundred dollars a month right what they
don't cover is that your success can be
and most likely will be zero that you
will in fact end up down hundreds of
dollars from underpaying some overworked
gig writer and thousands of dollars from
buying their course they say it's worth
thousands they say it's worth tens of
thousands with numbers they pulled right
out of their ass and that the thousands
they charge is a bargain so good that
it's practically theft what you're
getting today is all the bonuses right
here you know what they are for a bonus
value of over twenty one thousand
dollars bringing the total value of
everything you're getting today to fifty
six thousand dollars and you can get it
all right now for just one small
investment of nineteen ninety five they
tell you that it's so valuable so
worthwhile that you shouldn't even think
about it you shouldn't pause you should
just pull out your credit card and do it
do it now think later even if you're a
tiny bit unsure I need you to go there
and secure your spot in fact if you
can't afford it if you don't have two
thousand dollars to give them if you
don't have six hundred dollars to pay
their friends at the urban writers for
your first second third manuscript what
you need is some debt and if your card
gets declined which is completely normal
try again or just give a quick call to
your bank and approve of the transaction
and it'll go through so guys there's a
good debt and there's bad debt this here
is taking on good debt because the thing
is saying yes to this is a mental game
you know you want it you know you need
it what they're offering is less than
worthless it's predatory it is actively
harmful and I'm qualified to say that
because I'm the worth decider
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]